Simplifica 3x al cuadrado -8x más
7 más 2x al cubo - "x" al cuadrado más 8x -3 ¿Muy bien? Esto de simplificar es sumar y restar
términos para que esto sea una expresión un poco más sencilla. Sin embargo solo podemos sumar o restar términos si son similares.
Déjame hacer un pequeño recordatorio de que quería decir esto.
Por ejemplo si teníamos y si tenemos una "x" cuadrada y lo queremos sumar
con otro "x" cuadrada, sí podemos hacerlo por que tienen el mismo exponente y entonces, tendríamos 2x al cuadrado.
De manera similar si queremos sumar ¿No sé? Digamos un 3x al cubo con un 4x al cubo
4x al cubo entonces, también podemos sumarlos por que tienen el mismo
exponente y tendríamos 7x al cubo. Algo que no podemos hacer es simplificar
"x" al cuadrado más "x" al cubo por que ahora tienen
exponentes distintos entonces, esta expresión de aquí le voy a poner que no se puede simplificar.
No se puede simplificar,
¿Ok? Después de este recordatorio ahora si vamos al problema.
Entonces queremos sumar términos similares, los que tengan el mismo
exponente. Vamos a empezar con el exponente más grande que me parece que es 3,
si es 3 y al parecer nada más hay un sumando que tiene "x" al cubo y es este de acá el 2x al cubo.
Entonces ese lo voy a poner aquí abajo 2x
al cubo, vamos a ver que otros hay. Vamos a cuadrado.
Aquí tenemos un 3x cuadrada y aquí tenemos un -"x" cuadrada.
Entonces déjame juntar este 3x cuadrada y este -"x" cuadrada, todavía no los vamos a sumar nada más déjame escribirlos aquí.
3x al cuadrado - "x" al cuadrado
¿Ok? Vámonos con los que tienen "x" a la 1 los términos lineales entonces,
los voy a marcar con este color verde que sería -8x y 8x entonces le pongo -8x
más 8x y finalmente los términos constantes, que no tienen "x" o bien que podemos pensar que
están multiplicados por "x" a la cero. Entonces sería más
7- 3 ¿Muy bien? Entonces hasta ahorita lo único que he hecho es aprovechar la
propiedad conmutativa de la suma y la resta para reacomodar los términos y juntar los términos similares.
Ahora sí vamos a simplificar, vamos a realizar las operaciones.
Déjame tomar el morado entonces, este 2x al cubo se queda como 2x al cubo,
luego aquí tenemos 3x cuadrada y le estamos quitando una "x" al cuadrado, si a 3 le quitamos 1, nos queda nada más
2x al cuadrado ¿Si?
2x cuadrada luego aquí tenemos 8x
-8x ¿Si? O bueno -8x más 8x es lo mismo por que podemos
intercambiarlos pero, estamos cancelando pues todos los "x" ¿Verdad?
Entonces aquí nos quedarían 0x podría ponerle más 0x pero eso sería redundante entonces, simplemente no voy a escribir nada, y
finalmente hay que sumar 7 y restar 3, 7 -3 es igual a 4.
Entonces voy a ponerle más,
más 4 ¿Muy bien? Con esto terminamos y logramos simplificar la expresión y nos quedó 2x al cubo más 2x al cuadrado más 4.